okay now maybe you're starting to see
why I chose this question to do this but
before we do this practice paper I this
has some surprising teeth in it and by
the way I think I've spotted three or
four people who've managed to get out
and it's not as though it's not as
though this there's extra skills that
you need to have known like secret
knowledge that you need to have to solve
this question so there are a couple of
tips and tricks which can make it just
sort of all that but you sort of have to
know these things before but there's no
reason why you can't or solve this so
it's very interesting like I did or what
have you seen to hear a brick wall it's
like I've done all this algebra and one
of two things has happened number one
I'm not getting anywhere like I've
proved it's divisible by three which is
a relief because if it's divisible by 9
it better be divisible by three but
that's not enough and then what you've
got left is you can't work with it it's
got like seven and six is in it you're
like what we're supposed to do with this
all alternatively because you have done
so much algebra you sort of tripped
yourself over and you're like oh I've
proved it's not divisible by nine
that's a problem okay so how do you go
about this this is the like you've got
okay and I think most of you are
probably struggling because you are
trying to twist and turn this into a
form such that you can see this guy I
mean most people are looking for this
right so they are like ah I can see is a
3k plus one tucked inside there right
and there's also a 7 to the K inside
there so let me try and pull that apart
tease apart so that this this guy will
emerge and then I can use my assumption
okay now algebraically
it's like wrong with that it's just that
it doesn't catch you very far right or
anywhere at all
so I want you to don't just have a look
at what I've done right have I look at
my proof step which obviously I haven't
finished yet I think we all know we all
know it makes sense to go from here to
here and to get that proof step into a
form that's just sort of simpler because
like who was the leader like that okay
so everyone recognizes to do that
however most of us have not really paid
attention to
assumption and the way that it is
phrased we just kind of write it down
right we're so used to like this is this
is the difference between okay
this is an algorithm I know what to do
with this I'll just go ahead and I'll
just sort of mindlessly go through the
steps that's dangerous in our first two
bits here even though they use are
usually quite laborious okay this is not
the best form to use it you can't use it
in this form it'll work just fine I'll
show you where to do this at the end but
it might be easier to use this in a way
that allows us to connect it to this a
bit better okay the way I've seen some
people use it I think it is you um you
may wonder subjects right yeah okay
let's rewrite this and make one of the
subjects so this is gonna be one equaled
I guess I'll add this over here and I'll
subtract that over there is that okay so
I'm gonna go ahead let's see here
3k plus 1/2 the set times 7 to the K
minus 9 and whatever that happens to be
okay so this is equivalent this is
equivalent I can use this as my
inductive hypothesis as well just as
well okay so now I'm ready to actually
have a go my left hand side right this
this left hand side I'm trying to prove
heat so here's my proof the left hand
side naturally I have to write it as is
so I'm not gonna muck about with it I'm
not going to do any kind of substitution
or simplification at all that's what
I've got
that's a 1 and now I'm going to use by a
very very slightly tweaked version of
the inductive hypothesis right so
there's a 1 right there so I'm going to
substitute in for that one ok so I've
got 3 9 k + 4 - 7 k plus 1 and I'm gonna
bring it down take away what have I got
there 3 K + 1 7 to the K + 9 m did I
substitute it correctly you happy with
that yeah now just pause for a moment
and see why this is gonna be so much
easier to work with
to try and twist this out and twist and
turn it and see what you can go okay
because what I've done is I've pulled
these guys out right these are naturally
gonna talk the same language okay like
they're all in the three KS there's all
these seven to the KS flying around so
I'm gonna get a lot of collection of
like terms there and I've already got
this ablative I've already used and this
is where you should put this because
I've had a few people ask me this is
where you should write by assumption or
by inductive hypothesis we're still
getting a bit confused or like I know
I'm supposed to use it me where do I use
it
and the simple answer is wherever you
substitute some kind of form that you've
got here okay so now I'm ready to go can
someone suggest to me what might be some
things that we could do just not to
break this apart yeah take out a take
out of seven okay oh if I take out us
seven from here right then this is gonna
be you'll see why I write this in a
second this is gonna be twenty one k
plus twenty-eight sent to the cake yeah
take away this mini seven seven eight
right and now those of you who've put in
ten fifteen lines of algebra outside of
the Big O
why okay look at these right look at
what look at what you've got here and
21k take away three K is 18 K 28 take
away one is 27 for reals
really Plus this thing which I already
knows but divisible by Billy
so I'm gonna pull out my 9 here what's
that 2 k plus 3
I've already got my 9 there the rest of
this you can you can do okay another way
we multiply this by seven so you've got
that gives you your k plus one that make
my seven and that's 60 and then how did
you use that
okay yep so you've done something very
similar to us right you just took this
line you tweaked it just a little bit
before you actually chose to use it okay
so what I'm trying to highlight for you
is like this is not some fancy geometry
or integration or or whatever sort of
induction question but it highlights
that you know don't don't just leave
this or usually an autopilot when we do
these two okay
but but think before you leave this peak
way way way way is there a way that
might be more useful to me now it's
obviously much more difficult to sort of
spot when is that more like when should
I do that
when should I go back to the inductive
hypothesis and change it a little bit
and what you should have done was if you
didn't read it straight away which is
fine like I didn't do the straight way
you're gonna get through some lines down
here and pretty quickly it will emerge
that you're not getting very far on your
current path right so just pause stop
don't think oh well I've started these
15 lines I'd better keep going know when
you can say this is not working out for
me I'm going to come back and see if I
can work this a little differently um
let's just finish an officer 9 2 k plus
3 plus yeah right so this this is by n
right so I'm going to say that this is 9
n where 2 k plus 3 okay so therefore
statement is true
well now I'll just say one more thing
remember I said to you our this there's
a little trick that will help you do
this another way but it's not commonly
known what you're doing divisibility
tests right we've got about it this path
if this is a visit I 9 it should be 9
times something if this is divisible by
nine minutes times something else
okay um let's just think about multiples
of nine for a second right so what do
you think about that multiples of nine
these not only have a properties
individually right this is a way of
saying each of these numbers can
individually be standing this way okay
they also have properties together right
properties like between them for example
if you have a look at the gap between a
pair of these numbers right
all these two or these two or any pair
of these multiples of nine right the gap
between any pair is also going to be a
multiple of nine do you agree with that
so if you can say well I can't work with
these individually but if I can work
with the gap which actually is exactly
what I was doing here right this is I
taking the difference between two of
these little bit then if I could show
that that's divisible by nine then
that's just as easy and sometimes that
will make your algebra like if you're
subtracting things for each other which
have a lot in common to do it each other
that will make the algebra very simple
does that make sense so that's less well
known that's why I'm gonna show it to
you as a result cuz you'd be like how
was I supposed to do that but I think
all of us can know to do something more
like this when this is not working out
for us okay
you turn back the digits yeah there's a
really fun proof for why the digits no
but it adds up to a multiple of nine
which is the same as the divisibility
test for 3 and that can be proven by
induction well I mean you can even keep
going like say 108 still when you go to
the when you go to the next one what's
the next one still okay
what about you just keep going right now
if you if I say something like 900 and
well that's obviously yeah but it's the
digits add up to a multiple right
because you can and like I said there's
a really nice proof by induction you can
all do it if you want like a number can
be stated as like 10 like its digits
give me like ten a hundred a plus ten B
plus C right you can stay in this way
this is actually a you can sort of go on
and do it in any way you like it's a
really nice property that takes mid time